did you think that your data that was
seen by a gpt3
like model is safely compressed by it
hidden
among immense amounts of other data
then think again is this the end of
privacy
miss coffee bean did we not forget
something
let's say hello first how about that oh
sure
hello and welcome to this ai coffee
break where we
where we discuss how it has been
possible by a huge collaboration of
big corporate and university players to
extract training data from large
language models
like gpt2
large language models of billions of
parameters are here to stay
just think about bert gpt2 and gpt3
recently that made a lot of headlines
and made it into a coffee break video
and it is quite common that these
usually transformer based language
models are
trained on private data sets so this
paper
is telling us that they developed an
adversary
privacy attack that can extract verbatim
training data from models like
names phone numbers addresses or unique
identifiers
oh no in this case we want to know
why it is possible how bad it is
and what this would mean for models
other than gpt2
but first a little summary about
language models
a language model predicts the next token
given the previous ones
the best example for this is the gpd
family
for generating text with these models
one has to input some prefix which is a
sequence of tokens and let the model
predict the next tokens to complete the
sequence
and this is what this paper does with
gpd2 trained from public data scraped
from the internet
but bear in mind the data on the
internet is public but it is open ai
secret which
public data was included in the training
set
this secrecy is it not wonderful
okay joke aside this makes gp2 the
perfect
test case because the authors can attack
the model
and extract data from it and search
whether the extracted data can be found
on the internet
if yes it was most likely included in
the scraped
training set of the model but why is it
possible to extract
verbatim training instances from
language models
in the first place because language
models are memorizing things
if you prompt gpt2 to complete the
sentence
my address is first main street san
francisco california
it generates the correct zip code and
this kind of memorization
is good especially with things that have
no pattern attached to them
like unique identifiers person names
addresses
phone numbers pattern extraction is what
language models usually do
the majority of the model's weights
cluster data points to correspond to a
common pattern together
the spare weights if there are some
model the outliers the unique points
with no pattern that are left out of the
cluster
and memorized as they are and this
memorization is good to capture things
like
zip codes but become problematic when
things appear only once or twice during
training and get memorized
for this the authors define the bad type
of memorization
decay eidetic memorization in simple
terms it just means that the string
was k eidetic memorized if it occurred
k times in the training data and is
extractable from the language model
under this definition it is ok for the
model to memorize things occurring
thousands of times in the training data
but bad if k is small now we know that
memorization happens whether we want it
or not
because the model wants to minimize the
loss in the end
so if the model has enough weights left
to model the outliers and patternless
data points
memorization happens so how do the
authors exploit this memorization for
developing their
attack their pipeline is quite elegant
they take gpt 2 and generate 200 000
samples of text with gpt2
conditioned on all sorts of prefixes but
these generations are not necessarily
memorized pieces of text they could be
anything
so they sort and select the most likely
pieces to be memorized
text but the problem here is how to
decide whether text was memorized or not
one way to tell is by looking at the
probability of the generated text
gpt 2 assigns high probability for
memorized strings
because these data points are outliers
alone modeled by their own specific
weights
there is no uncertainty in prediction as
there is no neighbor data point that the
model can be misled by
and to really be certain that the high
confidence of the model comes from
memorization and not from other regions
the model could be certain about
the authors compare the probability also
to the output of a smaller version of
the model
one that doesn't have the spare weights
to model
these outliers then the sorted
generations are deduplicated
the top 100 are chosen and the
evaluation is ready to start by
searching the generated strings on the
internet to check
whether they can be found verbatim on
the world wide web
and how successful is this adversarial
privacy attack
well the situation is worrisome for the
best variant 67
of the generated texts are word by word
repeated snippets from the training data
okay so this was the bad news the
not that bad news is that the generated
snippets
are not only named individuals but also
things that are
okay like licenses or terms of use
the other thing that is not that bad is
this adversarial attack cannot target
specific
names or contact information it can just
generate things in bulk and miss coffee
bean just needs to hope it is not about
her
yet another good bad news is that even
though the paper makes the effort to
define
k eidetic memorization the tables do not
include the k that much
and when they do like in table 4 it
seems like the
k relates to the document count and not
to the number of occurrences
of the string in each document
so it seems that for strings to be
memorized by gpt2xl
they have to occur more than 30 times in
the document
it is very interesting to see how
smaller versions of gpt 2 need
many more string repetitions to memorize
since they have less
of the spare parameters to model the
outliers
but this also means that gpt3 with
hundred times more parameters than gpt2
would need far less repetitions of
strings to memorize them
and here is where the news is really bad
again even though this attack that we
have seen is not targeted or tuned for
finding the effective prefixes from
which the language model can generate
the worst memorization
the paper also shows an example of how
much better
a careful tuning of the prompts can be
when completing a prompt with the first
digits of pi
the first 25 correct digits are
completed
but when prompted with pi is the model
can output
799 digits and with
this prompt here it can output 824
correct digits how did the authors even
come up with this prompt
oh wow so what to do about it
the authors propose training with
differential privacy
where the long tail containing outliers
prone to memorization is removed from
training
they also mentioned curating the
training data
well this is hard if not impossible to
achieve with human manpower
since the data is huge fine tuning may
cause the models to forget the
memorization but might introduce
new ones then auditing the models for
memorization
seems a good practice and here is where
this paper fits very well
but it is kind of crazy that it took so
long for a study on these models to come
out
especially since this memorization issue
was known from lstms already
for all the juicy details read the paper
linked in the description below
do you also like the summary of
contributions at the end of the paper
miss coffee bean would love to see this
more often
let us know in the comments what you
think still here
now go read the paper or some other
paper
or anything else you enjoy like watching
another coffee break video
okay bye